[Applause]
thank you so much
for doing this with us we are such
barbecue fans here and i was just
wondering
if you guys could talk about your
experience as
women in a field that's you know been
sort of
categorically dominated by men but no
longer
so will you guys share that with me well
for me
i grew up in a barbecue family so it's
something that i'm used to
um and it was always male dominated and
also for me
i just want to you know i have two older
brothers that are both in barbecue and i
just wanted to show them little sis
could do it better than they could well
that
that is a healthy competitive spirit i'm
all for that
now you guys sent us your brisket it is
just the most
insane looking piece of meat i've ever
seen
what is the biggest secret to making
brisket
because it's such a staple in barbecue
you know i think it's patience
honestly and i mean
we really focus on i mean we really
focus on the fires and then
of course the cut of meat we use an
all-natural brisket
which is very important to us and it
comes from a happy farm the
cows are mainly raised no hormones
grass-fed
and so you can really taste the love
that the animals were given
well i very much appreciate the
humaneness
and the consciousness um
conscientiousness of that answer
and if you are interested in getting
deeper down the brisket rabbit hall with
some of the very best
please go to our website at
thedrewberrymore show.com
and the ladies are going to take you
through how to make their award-winning
brisket
now something that we can tackle here on
the show is the sides
um i am definitely salivating i don't
know if you've heard this about me but
macaroni and cheese is
well it's my happy place and my downfall
and everything in between
teach me the way ladies teach me oh i've
got you don't worry
so we do a uh a really nice
um kind of veggie mix with tomatoes and
poblanos and garlic and of course
jalapenos for that nice spice mix
we bake it um you know just
just until the um just until the veggies
are tender
and uh and then we will cool it down
we are going to stick it right here in
our blender
by the way what kind of blend are you
using a vitamix
of course i i actually i'm going to send
you a blender that has
like and i want to know your thoughts
really
i do i just made a blender um
and it's really a butt kicker so i'm
excited for you ladies to tell me if it
measures up or not
and you be you have to be honest oh it
looks great
all right are we ready all right so
let's blend it are you ready
all right got some melted cheese over
here
put that in there mix it up real good so
it just melts all together
okay so you want to get that nice color
oh wow
yeah uh-huh i love it so
then you're gonna put some pepper in it
and here at a barbecue we
uh use a ton of pepper and then you can
add a little bit of salt and it's just
kind of like to your liking
yeah just for a little bit of seasoning
then you're gonna
add those shells and cheese we use
shells because
um we really like how the cheese kind of
gets in inside it
you know holds all of that together and
you're just going to kind of fold it all
in
and then that's the creamy
magic we have together oh my god look at
that
this looks amazing essentially what
we're doing is
i can't go and adding shells and shells
to it
it looks amazing okay now um will you
take me through oh god
oh
and no i've had to cut myself off of
this many many times
okay now um will you take me through the
coleslaw
right now we're gonna do our um chipotle
coastline
this is our uh just a different take on
slaw it's a mayonnaise base
we start with the green cabbage red
cabbage and
carrots from there you're gonna add your
mayo
oh and then chipotle and you literally
that's to taste
however much spicy you want to do it we
do
the granulated garlic
dust it on top there you're going to add
your paprika
and do that another dusting
and then again heavy pepper and it's the
coarse ground pepper
because it gives it that nice crunch and
then the last one you want to add is
your salt to taste
okay now is it okay if i taste this
absolutely oh my gosh you guys this is
incredible
holy crap this is from the chipotle
yes get a little bit of adobo adobo
yes i taste it huh i love it you guys
don't cringe on your spice
oh my gosh you guys you're both so
talented and incredible and there's so
much hype and fuss about you guys and i
was so excited to meet you
thank you so much for having us i am so
honored you came on the show
and watch your backs because i am coming
for you ladies leanne
of lay barbecue the award-winning
restaurant and all of your food trip
trucks you're amazing
[Music]
you